in today's video i'll be showing you how
to dress like a zombie in
animal crossing new horizons
people of the internet's retrorackateur
here if we're meeting for the first time
i'm just a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell i post videos
every week here on youtube and also
stream over on twitch
today's video is all about
transformation you see halloween is
right around the corner which means it's
time to start picking out your animal
crossing costume
thanks to the latest update from
nintendo we can change our character's
skin to completely new tones including a
very pale white
green purple or blue we also get new eye
color options which now includes a
pinkish
red color orange yellow a light purple
gray or a new shade of green now i want
to know how are you guys planning to use
these different options in your
halloween costumes
let me know down in the comments below i
always love to hear what crazy fun ideas
you guys have
now first you need to actually purchase
these upgrades from the nook miles kiosk
using
nook miles tickets there are two
separate upgrades one for skin tones and
one for the eye colors
before i set out to change my eyes and
skin i thought i would head over to the
able sister shop to check and see if
they
had some clothing that looked a little
more i don't know zombie-like
alright so before i go in the able
sister shop of course i'm going to need
to remove my wetsuit so that's what i'm
going to do right here
also if you have on a wand outfit you'll
have to remove that as well
the snorkel though i can actually still
leave that on no problem and then i'm
just going in here to try and find
something that i think would look good
as a zombie so
and i'm not really seeing much out here
so i'm gonna go ahead and head on over
to the dressing room and see what i can
find in there
i do like the dog nose the dog nose is
pretty funny not sure it goes so well
with the zombie though
well would you look at me here in my
monocle and my mustache
nah nope not feeling it i'm kind of
thinking these acid wash
jeans up here they've got two different
options like the darker
on the left here and then the more
bluish tint on the right
from being completely honest nothing is
really jumping out at me hopefully i'll
be able to find some better halloween
items as we get closer to halloween i
think i'll go ahead and remove the
monocle
and probably remove the mustache as well
as cool as they may be oh what about a
fedora fedora might look pretty good
with this
no no not really feeling the fedora
either okay i need to get rid of that
bubble gum though before i
check out here so let me head on over
whoops okay yep definitely forgot to
remove the bubble gum that's fine i'll
just take it off here
from there you're going to need a vanity
or mirror funny story here guys somehow
i have not come across
either to this point and i have been
playing this game since
launch it's kind of crazy no recipes
nothing but never fear i have diana on
my island and i just knew she'd have a
mirror in her house
sure enough she did so if you don't have
a vanity or mirror of your own just
check in with your villagers go around
see what you can find and i bet you one
of them has one at first i didn't think
this would work because when you walk up
to the mirror and press
a the villager simply comments on the
furniture that you're looking at
but if you just press a again you'll
actually be able to access and use
the item now unfortunately the kind of
annoying part of this is you do have to
wait for the villagers to be
home in order to do this so i caught
diane at a good time where she happened
to be in her house
all right you know what before we head
over there let's throw on something else
how about these
bulb boppers right here oh yeah yeah
yeah definitely going with
the bulb bopper okay guys so once you
access this
as long as you have purchased the
upgrades you should see the four new
colors here
for the skin tone now let's go right
down there and take a preview oh my
goodness look at that
white that is super pale very very
creepy
take a look at the green and then the
blue how about the purple
man i actually think the white looks the
creepiest in my mind i'm kind of leaning
toward green let's see how it looks with
the eye colors though first
all right so let's jump over to the eyes
now i'm definitely going straight for
this
pinkish red color that we have here and
you know what let me look for more kind
of like a sleepy
hazy kind of eyes here i need to be a
zombie after all
should i change anything else here maybe
something with the mouth
nose nah i don't think so what about the
hair though yeah i need some
very disheveled hair here let's see what
i can find oh yeah that one
that one is absolutely perfect
absolutely perfect now i really do like
the pale white
with the reddish pink eyes but let's go
ahead and take a look at all the other
eye colors here so there's the gray
there's the pink or the purple the
yellow and then the
orange right there kind of more of a
dark brown definitely think i like the
red vest right there now let's see
how the red looks with the zombie green
the blue just looks like a smurf to me
it looks like a smurf i like the blue
but it just makes me think of smurfs
man it's it's kind of a toss up for me
between the green and the white as much
as i love the pale white i think i
ultimately gotta go with the more
standard
zombie color here i'm going with the
green
it's probably gonna freak diana out now
isn't it
no she doesn't react at all oh man i
thought she'd say something about you
look so wonderful
man i wish throughout the month of
october the characters would actually
react
to the changes that you've made that'd
be great okay now i kind of want to
change up my outfit again and see if i
can find something that looks even
better than this right here
you know what let's see what i have in
my own stash of clothing here i might
have something that works even better
here
oh the music fest shirt that that looks
pretty good awesome is the western shirt
i think the western one looks pretty
good too
yodel cardigan oh the pineapple aloha
shirt looks great i just need to find
some good shorts to go with it
ah i love the pineapple shirt but i'm
not feeling any of these shorts i need
some better shorts
how about the pj oh my goodness the pj
outfit
yes yes the pj outfit goes
perfect with a little ball bopper there
you go
ladies and gentlemen my animal crossing
character transformed
into a zombie now once halloween is over
or if at any point you decide hey
i'm not really digging this you can
simply access the vanity or mirror again
and change yourself back to normal don't
forget there's a special halloween event
set to take place from 5 p.m to midnight
on october 31st
you'll want to buy some candy from
nook's cranny in preparation for this
event just remember you can only buy one
piece of candy per day
and no eating the candy until after
halloween kids if you're new to animal
crossing i've prepared a full playlist
which you should see
right now on the right side of your
screen as always guys thank you so
much for watching i'll talk to you again
soon